[Musique]
crise énergétique remontée des taux
d'intérêt menaces de récession comment
garder le cap et aussi le moral quand on
dirige une entreprise aujourd'hui notre
invité spéciale c'est vous Nicolas
dufourk bonjour bonjour directeur
général de BPI France alors on vient de
le voir dans le droit reportage cette
PME alsacienne qui a vu sa facture
énergétique multipliée par plus de 4
évidemment elle n'est pas la seule
d'ailleurs on a vu le Medef tirer le
signal d'alarme est-ce que vous aussi
pour nos PME industriels vous êtes
inquiets
on est nombreux à avoir tiré le signal
d'alarme depuis le mois de juillet
sachant que le gouvernement faisant ses
comptes en septembre-octobre a fini par
sortir
il y a une petite mort il y a trois
semaines un dispositif important qui
représente plus d'une dizaine de
milliards d'euros de dépenses publiques
aujourd'hui ça a l'air de rien 10
milliards d'euros mais il y a quelques
années ça aurait été un plan gigantesque
et ce plan je ne sais pas si cette
société le compte dans la multiplication
par 4
énergétique probablement mais c'est un
plan qui est particulièrement généreux
que je peux détailler d'ailleurs si vous
le souhaitez mais mais tous ceux qui me
regardent je les incite à se rapprocher
des services
fiscaux de leur département puisque
c'est un guichet c'est un nouveau
guichet c'est un ancien fonctionnait pas
bien il a été l'ancien fonctionnait pas
bien on l'appelait Ukraine il faut que
c'est pas bien parce que les critères
qui avaient été imposés en réalité par
la Direction Générale de la Concurrence
de Bruxelles ça fait beaucoup trop
restrictif et donc personne en fait
n'était dans ce filet il a fallu
plusieurs mois pour renégocier ces
critères et les nouveaux critères sont
beaucoup plus favorables après la
facture pour l'ensemble des entreprises
cette facture énergétique ce sera 16
milliards d'euros nous a dit Medef pour
2022 est-ce que il y a assez d'argent
public encore une fois 10 ou 13
milliards d'euros face à cette flambée
je pense que aujourd'hui il y a une
douzaine de milliards d'euros on va voir
si ça suffit ce qui remonte en tout cas
du portefeuille de BPI France puisque
comme vous savez on est investi dans
1000 entreprises en direct et à peu près
5000 autres entreprises au travers des
fonds que nous finançons donc on a quand
même un échantillon tophétique sans
parler des entreprises auxquelles nous
faisons crédit c'est que pour l'instant
ça passe pour l'instant ça passe donc on
n'a pas les nouveaux tarifs vont arriver
en 2023 c'est peut-être là on verra la
réalité non alors par ailleurs par
ailleurs ce qu'il faut comprendre en
effet c'est qu'aujourd'hui les tables de
l'électricité sont les tarifs à terme
sur un marché qui est un marché
irrationnel tu as marché qui anticipe
que les centrales nucléaires ne vont pas
repartir que en revanche la guerre en
Ukraine va redoubler que etc donc les
prix à terme de l'électricité si vous
interrogez la Commission de régulation
d'électricité ou si vous interrogez RTE
notre grand réseau de distribution
d'électricité français sont totalement
irrationnels donc je pense que comme les
entrain de le faire français vont
repartir du mois de janvier ça ira mieux
on va y aller et je pense par ailleurs
que le marché va se calmer donc je pense
mais ça n'est que moi mais après tout on
est là pour livrer ces intuitions qu'à
la fin de 2023 on va retrouver un marché
d'électricité qui sera un marché
beaucoup plus raisonnable donc pas
besoin de mettre en place un bouclier un
bouclier tarifaire pour les entreprises
le client prochain il existe jusqu'à la
fin 2023 ce qui était annoncé par le
gouvernement c'est jusqu'à la fin 2023
donc il y a un guichet fin 2022 qui va
se poursuivre jusqu'à fin 2023 pour les
PME et pour les ETI pardon et pour les
PME un dispositif qui s'appelle
l'amortisseur qui est un dispositif
automatique un peu compliqué mais que
vous trouverez sur tous les sites
internet
va permettre de baisser de l'ordre de
120 euros le mégawatt
la facture d'électricité des PME
françaises pendant toute l'année 2023
bon on a un contexte économique et Nica
Dufour que qui n'est pas facile et c'est
un euphémisme et quand on voit le moral
des patrons et là c'est intéressant il
résiste c'est ce que nous dit l'Insee
qui mesure tous les mois ce qu'on
appelle le climat des affaires comment
on explique cette résilience et ce que
au niveau du terrain vous-même chez les
pays France vous avez même remontés
absolument et c'est l'enquête que nous
avons publié à trois semaines qui
l’enquête que nous faisons régulièrement
avec Rex & Co sur le TPE PME on fait
également une enquête ETI qu'est-ce
qu'elle montre cette enquête elle montre
que bon le bras n'est quand même pas
stable le moral décline un peu alors
est-ce que c'est le moral c'est
simplement les anticipations
d'investissement aujourd'hui
vous avez
quatre points de moins qu'il y a un
trimestre d'entrepreneurs qui disent
avoir ou vouloir investir en 2022 il est
vrai qu'on se rapproche de la fin
d'année 2022 quoi qu'il arrive donc
grosso modo en 2022 vous aurez un
entrepreneur sur deux qui aura investi
et on s'attendait à ce qui est 55 %.
voilà la différence on passe de 55 à 50
grosso modo donc c'est pas majeur
honnêtement ça veut dire que les
entrepreneurs français sont de plus en
plus résilients ils sont le plus de plus
en plus résilient pourquoi parce que un
leur carnet de commandes sont très bons
l'économie va bien la consommation tient
européenne on entend le mot récession
par tout imminente menace de récession
et là on parle de quand même commande
on se rapproche de la fin d'année on va
se dire qu'en regardant l'automne 2022
derrière nous là il y a eu un mouvement
de catastrophisme ambiant qui était lié
d'ailleurs au fait que la guerre était
imprévisible c'était l'époque où Poutine
parlait d'attaque nucléaire faut sauver
donc il y avait des raisons il y avait
des raisons d'être inquiets tout ça est
déjà un peu passé honnêtement et donc
[Musique]
l'économie française a tenu cette charge
cette charge émotionnelle très très
forte des mois de septembre et octobre
elle a vraiment tenu donc on va vers
quoi maintenant on va vers d'après
l'INSEE et c'est tout à fait ce que nous
anticipons chez BPI France deux
trimestres de très légères récession
moins 0, quelque chose et ensuite deux
trimestres qui vont reprendre de sorte
que à la fin d'année 2023 au total sur
les 2023 pour l'instant c'est ce qu'on
voit une légère croissance donc il y a
un trou d'air sur les deux prochains
trimestres il y a un trou d'air sur deux
projets trimestre qui est
essentiellement lié à la crise de
l'énergie il faut se le dire avec le
principal impact qu'on voit aujourd'hui
il y a cette flambée des prix d'énergie
et à ce ralentissement qui est quand
même là c'est l'investissement on voit
des investissements qui ne sont pas
annulés mais qui sont décalé il y a le
cas de ça prend moi qui m'a marqué de
voir sa Franck qui met sur pause pendant
12 18 24 mois un gros projet d'usine de
frein carbone du goûter Lyon à cause du
coût de l'énergie
n'a pas pris la décision d'abandonner
son projet de confiance et de construire
aux US il a juste reporté bon et
[Musique]
la raison pour lequel safran au fond a
fait son report c'est pas simplement la
crise de l'électricité en Europe c'est
le contrat entre la crise de
l'électricité en Europe et les prix
d'énergie extraordinairement bas des
États-Unis c'est ce contraste là qui
pose problème à un certain nombre
d'industriels qui sont électro-intensifs
notamment les activités de carbone de
safran mais on pourrait parler de la
chimie également et en particulier
allemande on va parler juste après de ce
plan XXL de subventions massive je
confirme qu'il y a des reports voilà
c'est ça
la première étape souvent le report mais
ne voyons pas le pire un petit mot juste
de la tension est-ce qu'attention ou pas
sur la trésorerie des entreprises au
travers de tout ce qu'on a dit flambée
encore une fois la facture énergétique
ralentissement je ne dirais pas qu'il y
a de tension il y a eu trésorias
bondante fin 2021 parce que l'année 2021
était la plus belle l'année
macroéconomique que la France est connue
depuis 30 ans qui fait suite à 2020
aussi et fait 400 euros mais l'effet
catapulte qui a produit énormément de
cash et il y a eu beaucoup d'argent
public aussi et tout ça surtout dans la
trésorerie des entreprises et puis
prenez sommet 2022
idem
je connais pas un entrepreneur qui ne
disent de premiers sommet 2022 canons
donc on est arrivé à l'été 2022 avec
beaucoup de trésorerie et cette
trésorerie en effet à l'automne 2022
elle est revenue à son niveau normatif
avant donc oui elle a baissé mais elle
est juste revenue à son niveau dermative
d'avant la demande de crédit très forte
la concurrence entre les banques est
très forte malgré la remontée on en
parlera après des tôles intérêts malgré
la montée taux d'intérêt et les taux de
sinistralité sont dérisoires fin 2022
les demandes de garantie sur des PG au
non remboursés sont très très faibles et
je vais être très garanti par l'État
et donc voilà voilà le paysage en effet
étonnant de la fin 2022 où on a eu très
peur mais l'économie tient la Financière
les infrastructures de financement
l'économie sont là et la sinistralité
faible mais l'impact le gros de l'impact
sera priori début 202300 on l'a compris
et certains voudraient croire que ce
choc énergétique est passager on
aimerait bien évidemment ce soit le cas
on a aussi des qui nous dit le contraire
que cette crise énergétique est là pour
durer bon après c'est leur point de vue
vous me direz mais ce qu'il faut s'y
préparer est-ce que ça la question
est-ce qu'on est préparé peut-être à une
nouvelle donne en matière de coût de
l'énergie qui se resterait à niveau
élevé alors c'est très difficile
d'anticiper ce qui va se passer est-ce
qu'on reviendra au coup au prix donc de
l'énergie d'avant il y avait un gaz
russe extraordinaire abondant qui
permettait de guider des prix
d'électricité extrêmement faibles
parenthèses plus faible que les coûts de
production du nucléaire probablement pas
est-ce qu'on aura donc une énergie
européenne qui sera compétitive par
rapport à l'énergie américaine
probablement pas compétitif par rapport
à l'énergie chin oui donc il y a un
sujet d'extrême compétitivité l'énergie
américaine
est-ce qu'on peut continuer de
développer une industrie européenne avec
une énergie un peu plus cher j'ai pas
dit massivement plus cher mais un peu
plus cher je pense que oui ça dépend
on met le curseur exactement c'est clair
que si on stabilise dans la durée à 180
euros le mégawatt c'est quand même un
choc pétrolier puisque ça fait trois
fois plus qu'avant donc il y a des il y
a des électro intensifs qui nous plait
une partie de l'aluminium etc et
d'ailleurs cette crise énergétique
provoque une un graphème de
compétitivité c'est ce que nous a
rappelé Geoffroy route des yeux le
patron du Medef d'ailleurs on a eu le
président de la République qui récemment
a reçu l'ensemble des industriels enfin
les plus gros européens pour les inciter
à rester en France et en Europe c'est
vrai que cette crise énergétique va
peut-être pousser beaucoup d'entreprises
industrielles notamment hors de France à
investir hors de France on pense
notamment aux États-Unis oui
alors ça dépend des secteurs de
l'industrie il y en a qui sont plus ou
moins consommateurs d'énergie il y en a
qui peuvent très bien tenir avec une
énergie un peu plus chère il y en a pour
lequel c'est en effet tout à fait
critique donc ça c'est simple si on veut
garder ces industries là qui sont celles
que vous avez cité tout à l'heure on
peut parler de la France mais je pense
surtout à l'Allemagne parce que c'est
l'Allemagne et c'est l'Europe de l'Est
qui sont ultra chargés en activité
industrielle électro-intensive il faudra
de la subvention publique et c'est ça
qui c'est ça qui va être débattu dans
dans les mois qui nous séparent de la
fin 2023 parce qu'aux États-Unis il faut
le rappeler Nicolas Dufourcq l'énergie
on se rend pas compte mais trois fois
quatre fois cinq fois moins cher qu'en
France et qu'en Europe donc on n'est pas
armes égales aujourd'hui en matière de
l'accès au prix de l'énergie
allemande un problème
tout le secteur de l'acier un problème
l'aluminium un problème la verrerie on
est actuellement de verre alia donc je
suis pas forcément extrêmement fier de
vous dire même si j'aime beaucoup Veolia
que Verallia ne dépend pas d'électricité
puisque verlalia c'est du fioul
donc il se trouve que les prix du jeu
sont faibles aujourd'hui puisque le gaz
bref pétrole gaz tout ça plutôt bien
baissé donc la verrine n'est pas n'est
pas n'est pas à proprement parler touché
cette ville-là
notre missionnaire a fait une tribune
avec lui Gallois ce matin dans les échos
c'est sûr que pour ça commence c'est
compliqué donc on va on va devoir
traiter ce problème en 2000 en 2023
c'est tout à fait clair avec un risque
une vague possible de
désindustrialisation encore une fois
pardon le mot est choquant mais c'est ce
qui alors qu'on avait commencé un petit
peu à rien industrialiser une prise de
conscience de l'argent public une
volonté qui peut-être se fracasse sur
cette crise énergétique si elle devait
durer ça c'est sûr que par rapport à aux
espérances du premier semestre et de
l'été 2022 après tant d'années
bien
c'est un peu le coup trois quoi c'est un
peu le coup de froid et et est-ce que
est-ce que ça condamne finalement
l'Europe a redémarré une phase de
désindustrialisation personnellement je
ne le pense pas parce que l'Europe ne
l'acceptera pas tout simplement parce
que l'Europe qui est quand même un
gigantesque au conflit industriel
aujourd'hui qui a beaucoup souffert donc
plein de pays et particulièrement la
France de sa des industrialisation ne
veut pas ressouffrir et en même temps il
veut pas retraverser ce qu'il a déjà ce
plan des Joe Biden qui a dégainé son
hiéral rendu une flèche en anglais des
subventions colossales plusieurs
centaines de milliards de dollars pour
financer des investissements industriels
vers je rappelle
7500 dollars d'aide pour tout achat
d'une voiture électrique produites sur
l'Amérique vous me direz en France on a
des aides mais elles sont pour tout les
véhicules quel que soit leur lieu de
production est-ce que l'Europe voilà
l'Europe ne doit pas rester les bras
ballants on doit favoriser aussi notre
industrie locale bien sûr mais c'est ce
qui va se passer
ne restera pas les bras ballants
mais c'est ce qui va se passer parce que
ce que ce que ce que le Congrès
américain a voté finalement
l'indication d'un changement radical
d'époque ou puisque les Chinois l'ont
fait les Américains vont le faire et les
Américains nous disent vous les
européens ou vous empêchera pas de le
faire on comprendrait que vous fassiez
comme nous ils viennent de le dire donc
ils l'ont dit il y a trois semaines
quand le président de la République
était aux Etats-Unis donc c'est
évidemment des choses qui vont être
discutées maintenant alors donc c'est un
nouveau monde on a les moyens pardon
parce que aussi il faut avoir des moyens
publics financiers alors s'aligner
encore une fois sur les standards de
subventions XXL américain bien sûr
on va dire que certains pays ont les
moyens oui les pays européens ont les
moyens l'Allemagne est un moyen la
France moins
mais mais c'est le finalement c'est le
paradoxe de la désindustrialisation
française c'est que on a moins à
protéger
quand vous voulez protéger tout le tissu
industriel allemand là il va falloir de
gros moyens il se trouve que les
Allemands les ont ils ont un deux fois
plus important rapporté au PIB que nous
ou de mouillés oui
après il y a aussi ce cavalier seul
allemand on a pu en parler juste avant
avec son plan de 100 milliards d'euros
pour soutenir les entreprises face à
cette crise de l'énergie et là on se dit
bon déjà est-ce que c'est très
coopératif on peut on peut en discuter à
côté nous on met 10 fois moins
c'est pas sur une année évidemment mais
quand même
il y a des jouets des carottes dans les
200 milliards et par ailleurs les 200
milliards sont encore validés par
Bruxelles c'est parce que Bruxelles a
validé dans les 10 milliards français
annoncés comme je le disais tout à
l'heure il y a un mois
ça dit les règles qui vont devoir
s'appliquer aux Allemands aussi mais
50 % d'augmentation etc est-ce que ça
fait 200 milliards je ne pense pas bon
par ailleurs ce qu'on compte pas dans le
dispositif français tout est un peu
technique pour nous nos auditeurs mais
c'est la reine la reine c'est-à-dire ce
dispositif subventionnel qui permet à
EDF de vendre de l'électricité nucléaire
un tarif extrêmement faible à des
distributeurs qui vont pouvoir
faire de la marge sur cette électricité
là et développer un marché concurrentiel
de l'électricité en France voilà donc le
tarif de la reine il est à de mémoire 80
euros c'est un tarif qui est
subventionnel et il est subventionnel et
donc votre idée c'est quoi derrière et
ben c'est que donc ça a un coup et ce
coup-là il faut le rajouter ou dire que
j'ai les Allemands nous disent vous êtes
gentil de dire que 200 milliards c'est
trop mais vous dans ce que vous avez
annoncé vous comptez pas ce que vous
coûte la reine
d'ailleurs au finance publique je la
reine c'est certainement plusieurs
dizaines de milliards je crois 80
milliards
face à tout ça et pour lutter contre
cette spirale inflationniste on change
de sujet mais quand même c'est lié c'est
cette banque centrale européenne qui
remonte rapidement c'est toléré et là
c'est le thème de l'émission Les vents
contraires que subissent nos entreprises
il y a ce choc énergétique il y a aussi
et c'est un intérêt qui remonte et on
dit évidemment que c'est pas très bon et
c'est pas de bonne augure pour les
boîtes qui qui veulent investir ça coûte
cher d'investir ou qui doivent se
refinancer ou qui sont très endettés et
parfois c'est lié
ça c'est sûr que la Banque centrale
européenne souhaite aller dans son rôle
mais ça fait encore une fois un bon
contrat de plus c'est un bon contrat de
plus mais il faut qu'elle réussisse il
faut il faut il faut qu'on tue cette
inflation
donc il y a pas de solution d'être
solidaire de cette politique là il faut
qu'on revienne à 3 3% plus d'inflation à
la fin 2023 parce que sinon ensuite on
est dans des désordres économiques qui
deviennent beaucoup beaucoup plus
coûteux bon donc le sujet c'est est-ce
que les taux d'intérêt vont rester
durablement à ce niveau là c'est à dire
pendant de nombreuses années de sorte
que quantité de confinement deviennent
deviennent influençablement elle était
ça c'est une question qui est encore
ouverte plus rapidement on aura on aura
tapé cette inflation plus on aura
vraiment cette question plus on pourrait
imaginer que c'est un vrai risque
bien sûr
notamment le financement de la
transition énergétique qui a coûté
évidemment très très cher comment face à
tous ces vents contraires on les a cité
un remonter rapide taux d'intérêt
tension sur les approvisionnements on en
parle pas mais on sait que c'est aussi
compliqué même si elle était un petit
peu moins pour les employeurs les chefs
d'entreprise cette inflation qui est
galopante et qui doit être cassée par
par des banques centrales
justement les chefs d'entreprise peuvent
garder le cap c'est pas facile et le
moral et rester positif dans cette
tempête
vous qui les grâce à l'innovation en
réalité c'est à dire que si vous savez
c'est un coup si l'innovation c'est un
coup oui tout n'a d'ailleurs pas
forcément un coup gigantesque mais le
simple fait que vous
soyez féconds tout simplement avec des
nouveaux produits des nouvelles technos
des nouveaux brevets donc une projection
vers l'avenir et fait que
par le mix qualité prix de vos produits
vous pouvez absorber des chocs c'est sûr
que si vous continuez de vendre ce que
vous vendiez en 2018
ça peut mal se terminer voilà donc c'est
là qu'on trouve le mandat de BPI France
j'allais faire le lien son cœur c'est
que c'est que pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait
France 2030 54 milliards d'euros
aujourd'hui sur les 54 milliards on a
déjà déployé nous et puis les autres
opérateurs sur la première année de
France 2030 et on aura déployé à peu
près 10 milliards d'euros quand même et
sur les 10 milliards PPI France 8 8
milliards en un an uniquement pour
financer l'innovation donc c'est c'est
pour moi la grande solution
après il faut renouvellement de l'offre
et pour ça il faut aussi des
entrepreneurs il faut oser il faut il
faut voilà il faut oser entreprendre
prendre des risques mais pas tout le
long de la lame d'un entrepreneur non
plus
oui alors il y a quand même beaucoup
beaucoup de Français qui ont cette fibre
là beaucoup beaucoup pour peu que c'est
vos questions absolument pour peu que il
sache lutter contre leur propre peur
et là le rôle de la BPI aussi c'est de
dire à tout le monde attendez on est là
on est là carrément avec une boîte à
outils incroyable la beauté aussi les
plus profondes du monde et puis il y a
pas que nous c'est à dire que vous avez
la santé gratuite l'éducation gratuite
les infrastructures etc donc vous êtes
dans un pays dans lequel quantité de
risque non couverts à l'étranger sont
couverts par la société française et
donc vous pouvez être entrepreneur si
vous en rêvez mais allez-y j'attends
qu'il faut ce modèle social qui est
généreux qui est très bien comme ça il
faut pour le pérenniser il faut il faut
plus de plus d'entreprises plus
d'activités plus plus plus quoi non mais
absolument mais je pense d'ailleurs que
les Français sont prêts à ce qu'on dise
cela et qu'on exprime au fond cette
vérité qui est que dans un pays
ultra protecteur on peut être ult
entrepreneur et que l'un ne va pas sans
l'autre
il faut être ultra entrepreneur pour
financer le modèle social et parce qu'on
peut être ultra- entrepreneur donc tous
ceux qui nous regardent aujourd'hui et
qui se disent qui se révé le matin à 6h
dans le demi-sommeil et en se disant je
suis peut-être en train de passer à côté
de ma vie
ils sont nombreux je pense en France il
faut leur dire pas de problème non c'est
vous
et vous avez cette conviction que la
France a un potentiel inexploité ça je
le sais je vous connais oui ah oui non
ça j'en suis absolument convaincu la
France il faut faire monter sa
température à haut niveau hein grosse
température et là elle est capable de
choses extraordinaire merci pour cet
entretien Nicole dufourc directeur
général de BB France rappel votre livre
la désindustrialisation de la France
chez Odile Jacob qui n'est pas une
fatalité la crise énergétique ne nous
aide pas mais le combat n'est pas perdu
d'avance je veux qu'on finisse sur une
autre positive aucun combat n'est perdu
avant et quand on est compatible en
général on gagne allez merci à vous
merci c'est la fin de pourvu que ça dure
l'émission qui rend les co-responsables
sur Public Sénat émission à voir ou
revoir sur Public Sénat le repas bien
sûr vous le savez c'est public c'est un
point fr on se retrouve dans deux
semaines
[Musique]